nothing has been solved the situation is
worse as adverse as it was at the
beginning and we literally burnt money
by trying to bail it out hi I'm Matt
Welch for recent TV I'm in Las Vegas at
Freedom Fest annual event for
libertarians the world over speaking of
the world over I'm here in the Austrian
Austrian barber home she's the president
of the Hayek Institute in Vienna Austria
thank you for joining us thank you tell
us a little bit about the Hayek
Institute what did the Austrians do in
Austria
well we bring back the Austrians to
Austria literally fifteen years ago
there was no Hayek in Austria and people
did not know their Nobel laureate in
economics so we do a lot of university
programs we do teach we run big
conferences we have our free market Road
show which is touring Europe this year
the topic was Europe and the road to
serfdom everybody in America is
wondering what the hell is going on in
Europe and what's happening with the
euro and disintegration give us an
Austrian Austrians take on the current
euro crisis and well finally the truth
comes to the surface the welfare states
as we know them don't merge socialism
doesn't burst and this is what we see
right now redistribution is something
that doesn't work we have been living on
other people's money for way too long
our economy is
to diverse our countries are too diverse
you this one-size-fits-all policy the
brussels wants to oppose on everybody in
europe has no future and with the
weaknesses are actually due to the
financial crisis and then the sovereign
debt crisis
everything was visible all of a sudden
we just prolonged the problems for a
very long time in the 1990s I think
Western Europe privatized something like
seven trillion dollars worth of stuff
even really was on the cutting edge of
actually going into an interestingly I
would say positive direction and even
part of the preparations of the euro
what kind of part of that process if
people had to get their finances
allegedly in line is a kind of thing
where it's you know it there was a
fundamental deal with a devil at the
beginning of something that could have
been good or is it just a hopeless from
the beginning that kind of integration
well the idea having the four liberties
is great and this is what we need but we
don't need a strong centrally planned
government we neither need a centrally
planned tax code all over Europe
harmonizing all the taxes we know that
competition is the best thing also
competition of tax regimes so this is
one thing second thing if we if we look
at those diversity we have in the
countries the obvious things are the
languages but also the labor laws are
diverse the mentality of the people is
diverse the productivity is diverse the
industry is evers so you can't put this
into one-size-fits-all
so the at the beginning as you pointed
out in the 90s the first steps towards
privatization and liberalisation we're
great now it's more freedom
and of course economic growth but now
they just turned around 180 degrees with
all the new regulations especially after
the financial crisis prediction time
Greece is not going to stay in the euro
what about Spain Spain we have the
problem of individual debt not severing
that like for example breathe so it's
the individual indebtedness and we have
a problem with the caucus which are the
local banks the small banks those banks
are indebted as well so you cannot
compare these two countries but coming
back to your question yes Greece will
have to leave the euro sooner or later
because the imbalances are rising after
three years of pouring money into Greece
nothing has been solved the situation is
worse is as worse as it was at the
beginning and we literally burn money by
trying to bail it out so we just
prolonged the problem but there was no
solution can you point to countries
where you see positive action in terms
of reforming pensions reforming the
structure of welfare state ISM 20 years
ago 25 years ago Island was the pool man
the sick man of Europe and then turned
out by really market-based solutions to
become a hero and the star of course
they focused very much in a financial
industry and by then they were you know
they were caught on this in the trap but
they solve their problems and they will
be on the sound and solid bass very soon
again so I don't see problems for them
very good for recent TV thank you very
much Barbara coal mine Matt Welch see
you soon